[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 11 avril
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition une réunion pour discuter de
l'avenir des républicains élus et
militants l ère des yvelines se
réunissait hier à trappes dans un
contexte de tensions au sein de la
fédération
le président du département pierre
bédier a profité de la soirée pour
appeler au rassemblement du parti
invité de ce journal jean pierre
sevestre et grégory gary astier les
maires de coignières et maurepas ont
annoncé lundi leurs envies de fusionner
réunir les deux villes au sein d'une
seule commune nouvelle le rapprochement
pourrait être actée dès le 1er janvier
elle nous entendrons notamment quelques
réactions d'habitants enfin il en existe
seulement 120 exemplaires en france un
robot chirurgical d'un nouveau genre a
débarqué à l'hôpital privé des
franciscaines à versailles ses missions
assurées le chirurgien l'ordre des
opérations et faciliter le
rétablissement des patients
et puis autre invité de ce journal
damien guille et rédacteur en chef de la
gazette saint quentin en yvelines c'est
un un nouvel hebdomadaire gratuit qui
arrivent sur le territoire la semaine
prochaine rompre les inégalités assurer
une cohésion entre les territoires
franciliens ambitions du pacte de
solidarité interdépartemental présenté
ce mercredi au salon des maires d'île de
france s'il est lancé par les sept
départements de la région dont les
yvelines pour favoriser l'entraidé entre
les collectivités
ce pacte est constitué de deux volets un
fonds de solidarité pour soutenir les
départements d'île de france les plus
pauvres un dispositif qui existe déjà et
qui devait qui devrait passer de 60
millions d'euros par an actuellement à
181 millions et puis un fonds
d'investissement de près de 200 millions
d'euros pour intervenir sur de grands
dossiers à dimension supra aides
départementales et je vous le disais
dans les titres une réunion sur l'avenir
du parti les républicains étaient
organisées hier à mardi à trappes
l'occasion pour le président du
département pierre bédier deux prôné le
rassemblement
le candidat pour prendre la tête de la
fédération évinoise a voulu calmer le
jeu alors qu'une fronde s'organise
contre lui au sein de l air 78è les
détails avec ce sujet de mickaël millero
une réunion pour préparer l'avenir des
républicains l'objectif de cette
rencontre débat organisée ce mardi 10
avril à trappes
après une année 2010 est marquée par la
défaite de françois fillon dernière
présidentielle
on a une vraie crise qui est une crise
d'abord de compréhension qu'est ce qui
est arrivé qu est ce qui nous est pas
vie pour reconstruire
la grande partie droite un débat qui
s'est tenu sur fond de divisions
internes pierre bédier en course pour le
poste de président la fédération l ère
des yvelines a vu sa candidature
contestée dans une tribune par près de
150 élus locaux dans ce contexte
alexandra dublanche élus de sartrouville
a annoncé sa candidature
moi je ne prends pas ça comme une
opposition à billère b dire - je pense
et je le regrette un que cette pensée il
ne la partage pas qui vaut mieux faire
une équipe parce que le débat qu'on va
ouvrir il faut faire attention voilà je
pense que nos militants sont encore
convalescents nos jeunes amis je pense
qu'il faut affirmer une autre idée bon
c'est sûr moi c'est le principe de la
démocratie
la soixantaine de militants présents
dans la salle est divisée sur le sujet
est ce qu est il vraiment une division
mois pour moi il y a
divergence de point de vue ça reste une
élection interne il faut que ça se fasse
dans la dent dans une dans une certaine
sérénité et de surcroît faut bien se
rappeler que à la fin il faudra qu'on se
réunisse tous derrière un seul et même
président les élections qui doivent se
dérouler en interne en octobre prochain
seront sans doute animé ce mouvement
justement est un courant au sein du
parti les républicains sens commun est
née au moment de la manif pour tous en
2013 à sa tête désormais une yvelinoise
laurence trochut 44 ans a été désigné
lundi présidente nationale de sens
commun est la conseillère départementale
du canton de montigny le bretonneux
succède à madeleine de jessey le
mouvement compte dans les yvelines une
trentaine d'élus laurence trochut qui
évoquait sur notre antenne son
engagement au sein de sens commun elle
était l'invitée de wilfrid richy dans le
café politique retrouve des gens qui se
sont engagés au sein de la manif pour
tous au sein de sens commun avec une
vision plutôt de droite catholique
traditionnelle organo il ya de tout dans
ce sens commun c'est à dire que c'est
pas un parti à confessions
c'est un parti confessionnel on ne
demande pas de certificat de baptême ou
de certificats d'appartenance à une
religion quelconque et il ya de toute
façon dans ce sens commun plusieurs
plusieurs religions représenter
j'imagine en tout cas ça n'est pas un
mouvement labellisé catholique
c'est un mouvement qui est né
effectivement dans la foulée des
mouvements sociétaux de la manif pour
tous voilà
mais avec non pas une orientation on va
dire d'être un lobby d'être des trains
un think tank mais d'être vraiment un
mouvement politique est en ce sens un
mouvement politique ça s'intéressent à
tous les sujets s'intéresse pas
uniquement à la question du mariage pour
tous comme le faisait la manif pour tous
soyez donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
la même démarche
on va dire saint quentin en yvelines
bientôt peut-être à 11 et non plus 12
communes c'est en tout cas et le schéma
vers lequel on pourrait se diriger lundi
maurepas et coignières ont annoncé leurs
envies de rapprochement une fusion des
deux villes en une seule commune
nouvelle
elle annonce qui a fait réagir vous
l'entendrez dans un instant a été faite
par mes deux invités jean pierre
semestre
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le maire sans
étiquette de coignières et et grégory
jarry astier bonsoir bonsoir mr les
républicains ne mord pas alors maurepas
et et coignières partagent un même code
postal 78 310 des projets intercommunaux
comme une police municipale ou un centre
aquatique notamment devenir une seule et
unique commune nouvelle c'est la suite
logique des choses
finalement c'est la suite logique dans
l'environnement actuel effectivement
nous pensons compte tenu de la baisse
régulière des dotations de l'état nous
pensons qu ensemble nous pouvons agir
beaucoup mieux nous pouvons continuer à
apporter à nos administrés les services
que nous leur apportons et nous
faciliterons ensemble la cette
performance cette baisse des dotations
de l'état dont vous parlez les
récurrentes depuis 2014 c'est un manque
à gagner pour combien pour vos communes
n'aura pas par exemple alors c'est plus
de 2 millions d'euros de moins depuis
et je ne parle pas à défendre par
équation où on a perdu également peu
près 400 mille euros donc on est dans un
contexte très compliqué et nous savons
est aussi favorisée par la loi dans le
sens où la création des communes
nouvelles
dans le projet de finances 2010 8
l'aide financière a été relevé au delà
de dix mille habitants soit un plafond
de 150 mille habitants donc c'est aussi
une opportunité
et comme je viens de le dire mon
collègue jean-pierre la volonté c'est
surtout de servir l'intérêt général et
de proposer à nos habitants des qualités
de service public identiques voire
meilleure qu'auparavant
oui pour maintenir ce niveau de qualité
de service public aussi peut-être éviter
de passer par le levier fiscal augmenter
les impôts locaux c'est l'unique
solution aujourd'hui
alors actuellement actuellement si nous
considérons si nous considérons le
levier fiscal il n'est pas envisageable
globalement nous avons effectivement sur
les années à venir à contrôler et à
contrôler nos dépenses
d'accord il nous faut absolument
contrôler nos dépenses d'une façon très
stricte ce que nous avons déjà fait
depuis plusieurs années mais il nous
faut continuer et je pense qu'avec une
union avec non pas nous pouvons
mutualiser les services
ce que nous avons déjà fait vous l'avez
cité avec la police intercommunale
nous l'avons déjà fait avec d'autres
services et je pense que effectivement
cette union nous permettra par cette
mutualisation par cet ensemble d'une
cote d'une ville de 24 mille habitants
lors de cette création de communes
nouvelles et puis ensuite une ville qui
ne demandera qu'à grossir compte tenu
des objectifs de logements nos objectifs
de démographique
je pense que nous pouvons réaliser des
réductions de dépenses globales sensible
alors c'est une annonce vous l'imaginez
bien qui a fait beaucoup réagir depuis
lundi melani poquet michael et lui
d'euros sont allés interroger quelques
habitants de vos communes regarder ça
peut être un puce maintenant après je
sais pas c'est une bonne chose voilà
parce que on n'a pas vraiment tout ici
mais à maurepas il ya beaucoup de choses
donc sa proximité pour nous tu peut
obliger aussi actuellement 2
travailler ensemble pour pouvoir encore
plus de réactivité
bah c'est une bonne chose ça pour ça
permet un rapace à rapprocher les
habitants les uns avec les autres
les gens qui habitent à cogner arrive
enfin bloque aussi si l inverse au
commerce en plus de nous étendre un
petit peu sur le secteur et moi je pense
que c'est bien ce que les villes sont
grandes mieux mieux ça sera gérée plus
on aura de le potentiel pour pour
investir et pour avoir une grande ville
c'est bien ça évite les frais je pense
donc on divise les frais par deux
m'aurait pas conyers et ça je vais dès
que ça soit il a un coût et on m'aurait
pas mais moi je suis un trou pas
l'utilité su tout cas c'est un peu plus
éloignés et lincou a des réactions plus
mitigées sur notre page facebook depuis
la diffusion de notre reportage lundi
sept internautes par exemple se dit
plutôt favorable au projet s'il service
public n'en pâtit pas aimer regrette une
prise de décision rapide sans
consultation des citoyens
un autre commentaire fait remarquer que
cette décision ne faisait pas partie de
vos programmes respectifs en 2014 lors
des dernières municipales et il faut par
conséquent organiser un référendum
grégory christ est ce que vous avez
prévu de consulter vos habitants sur la
question peut-être les associer aussi à
une décision finale
alors déjà il ya plusieurs points kevin
est abordée et je me rends compte que
dans votre reportage est quand même
beaucoup de d'avis positifs dans la
réflexion qui est la nôtre c'est à dire
d'une démarche constructive et positive
est ce que nous proposons aux habitants
c'est une création de communes nouvelles
historique qui va compter justement pour
permettre toujours d'investir après la
volonté c'est évidemment de consulter
nos populations
on n'a pas encore déterminé la forme
mais il faut évidemment que nos
populations pu s'exprimer
là il faut bien que nos concitoyens
comprennent nous sommes contre
l'immobilisme et nous proposons une
quelque chose de positif pour continuer
à servir nos habitants et donc nous
lançons une réflexion nous allons lancer
des concertations des ateliers de
travail dans les semaines qui viennent
avec un rythme qui va être très souple
et donc ce sera l'occasion de nos
habitants de pouvoir s'exprimer et dans
des conseils municipaux qu'on va voir de
manière justement j'avais vous relancez
là-dessus la marche à suivre auprès des
conseils municipaux respectifs qu'elle
était en géant alors effectivement la
marche à suivre nous allons avoir un
conseil ministériel municipaux simultané
le 2 mai prochain
d'accord au cours desquelles eh bien
nous allons voter le lancement des
études de prospective sur cette création
de communes nouvelles coignières mopao
mort par deux poignards c'est qu'il y
aura des lois font les mois les mois
prochains
alors vos conseils municipaux respectifs
ensuite il y aura des informations et
des concertations des écoutes de toute
notre population au cours de la 17 mois
à peu près environ à venir pour avoir
effectivement les avis de la population
des administrés il ne faut pas se
contenter de la vie effectivement des
élus mais de tous les administrés
effectivement au cours des mois
prochains
une date butoir c'est le 1er janvier
2019 oui alors pourquoi le 1er janvier
2019 pour que ce soit clair pour tout le
monde sait que la loi nous demande
si nous souhaitons aller dans une
création de communes nouvelles de le
faire avant cette date parce qu'on ne
peut pas modifier la carte et communales
un envers les élections municipales et
aussi pour bénéficier des aides de
l'état
il faut que cette création de communes
nouvelles souhaite engager à cette date
mais c'est que le début il ya l'acte
politique de la création et ensuite il
va se passer des années pour construire
un projet administratif parce qu'il faut
penser aussi aux agents municipaux et un
projet de territoire au 1er janvier 2010
a du coup il y aura une commune où c'est
un projet qui peut être abandonné entre
temps il y aura une commune aux ailes
c'est un projet positif c'est un projet
positif et donc 1er janvier prochain je
pense qu'il y aura la création d'une
commune nouvelle
réunissant amour pas à coignières je le
pense profondément
et donc c'est une aventure comme l'a
précisé gregory gary astier et la
commune nouvelle sera créé le 1er
janvier 2019
effectivement il n'y aura la réunion des
deux conseils municipaux au sein d'une
même commune d'accord jusqu'à l'élection
de 2020 the des mains pour convaincre
deux dernières questions vous parliez
justement des de la question des agents
un commentaire avec émergent sur
facebook également combien de
suppressions de postes au sein des
services publics c'est une question qui
a été posée sur notre page facebook
une fusion est ce que ça veut dire que
va y avoir aussi une réduction
d'effectifs au sérieux ces seuls mairie
c'est pas une fusion
c'est une création de communes nouvelles
et donc c'est un peu comme dans un
mariage
chaque fiancée apporte son passé son
historique d'accor ses compétences et
donc on va faire une alliance un vrai
mariage et donc il n'est pas question de
suppression pourquoi voir le côté
négatif des choses justement cette
création de communes nouvelles va nous
permettre de maintenir nos services
publics tels qu'ils sont et voire même
de les améliorer en fédérant l'ensemble
de nos compétences
alors que finalement si nous n'allons
pas dans cette direction nous savons
qu'à terme de toute façon c'est soit la
suppression de services publics ou soit
de l'augmentation forte d'impôts locaux
et nous ne souhaitons pas aller dans
cette direction
en tout cas ça sera ma dernière question
une seule en scène un seul conseil
municipal un seul maire est ce que c'est
à dire que l'un de vous deux va se
retirer au profit de l'autre dernière tu
as certainement qu'elle
2 va se retirer au profit dans cet ordre
c'est en 2020 effectivement même en
début 2019 saluera des signes de reprise
et or l'a effectivement l'élection d'un
maire délégué une mairie
effectivement annexée merci à vous
jean-pierre sevestre et grégory galère
de coignières et maire de maurepas
d'avoir été avec nous et une actualité
un que l'on suivra bien sûr dans les
prochains mois avec attention sur atv 78
ont quelques hits quelques instants
saint quentin en yvelines pour un aparté
santé dans ce journal un robot
chirurgical pour assister à les médecins
alors des opérations c'est la nouvelle
acquisition de l'hôpital privé les
franciscaines à versailles il en existe
120 de ce type en france
un appareil qui permet une durée
d'hospitalisation plus courte et un
rétablissement des patients plus rapide
reportage de camille lambert attention
certaines images peuvent choquer
il a des allures de cockpit ce robot
chirurgical nouvelle génération a
rejoint la clinique privée des
franciscaines à versailles d'avancé ici
c'est son nom permet d'offrir de
meilleures conditions d'hospitalisation
pour les patients mais aussi pour les
chirurgiens pour le docteur g ne vois
c'est une première beaucoup moins
fatigués au lieu de rester deux à trois
heures debout en tenant des instruments
donc les épaules un peu surélevé
là on a ainsi à la console du robot et
puis on a voilà on est moins crispés sur
les pinces
on a une liberté de mouvement qui est
sans équivalence en coelioscopie et une
vision en trois dimensions qui fatiguent
beaucoup moins cette patiente souffrait
d'une descente d'organes avec ses bras
et ses pinces articuler le robot a
permis d'accrocher plus facilement des
bandelettes pour stopper la maladie à
l'origine utilisés dans la chirurgie
urologique
ce robot peut aussi être utile en
gynécologie le docteur apfelbaum
l'utilisent chaque semaine depuis le
début de l'année c'est un vrai plus pour
le patient en terme de ce qu'on appelle
la réhabilitation précoce j'ai vraiment
l'impression que les patientes sont
beaucoup plus confortable
j'ai eu une courbe d'apprentissage parce
que c'est vraiment une technique
nouvelle qui s'est tout à fait bien
déroulée et qui vous permet de maintenir
en tête d'accéder à des cas difficiles
j'ai vraiment l'impression que le geste
est plus simple dans les cas difficiles
seul inconvénient à prendre cette
nouvelle technique et le coût pour les
hôpitaux
le premier robot arrivé il ya sept ans à
la clinique a été remplacé par ce modèle
à 2 millions d'euros
il en existe seulement 120 dans toute la
france un nouvel invité m'a rejoint en
plein tôt damien guigné bonsoir avec le
rédacteur en chef de la gazette saint
quentin en yvelines alors c'est un
nouvel hebdomadaire gratuit qui arrivent
sur le territoire première publication
arrêtez moi si je me trompe c'est ce
mardi 17 avril c'est ça alors le titre
la gazette qui est déjà présent dans une
horrible in on en parle après pourquoi
venir première question pourquoi venir à
saint quentin en yvelines pourquoi
finalement proposer une édition sur sur
ce territoire
on a déjà une édition dans le nord des
yvelines qui marche relativement bien
puis des opportunités qui sont de fait
qui sont faites à saint quentin en
yvelines et puis vu le dynamisme du
territoire on s'est dit que c'est un
endroit où on pourrait arriver puis
proposer à nouveau un nouveau titre aux
habitants en quoi ce territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines 12 communes 230
mille habitants 16 mille entreprises qui
sont présentes sur le territoire en quoi
ça un territoire intéressant pour
traiter justement l'actualité locale
on connaît le dynamisme que ce soit au
niveau des entreprises most hid des
différents projets qui peuvent être
menées à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un territoire aussi qui propose un
nombre de sujets variés de par les
habitants qu'ils habitent
donc on ne doute pas de trouver de quoi
nourrir notre notre journal toutes les
semaines que ce soit au des sujets
associative des grands projets du sport
des faits divers de la culture on sait
qu'on va pas manquer de matière sur ce
territoire justement sont présents
d'autres médias locaux des télévision
une radio plus
titres de presse le rôle du média local
vous juger comment quel rô le primordial
at-il auprès justement des habitants de
ces territoires locaux assez d'abord les
informer puis les informer de la vie
locale de ce qui se passe et des
informations qui n'auraient pas
forcément sans la richesse de des
différents médias qui sont présents
d'accord et puis c'est aussi de
participer à cette nuit locale peut-être
leur leur apprendre des choses dont ils
n'ont pas conscience qui se passe juste
à côté de chez eux puis souvent tous les
sujets qui sont traités à part des
médias nationaux avant ça en général
souvent sont traités par des médias
locaux parce qu'ils sont les premiers à
être au courant bien bien souvent
première parution on l'a dit ce mardi à
17 avril à quoi ressemblent ces derniers
jours avant cette première publication
vous êtes trois rédacteurs sur cette
édition saint quentin en yvelines
vous êtes en totale effervescence là sur
ces paroles dans tous on est tous à fond
on prépare nos sujets on a commencé à
courir les premiers sujets dès la
semaine dernière il y avait beaucoup de
prise de contact avec tous les
différents acteurs du territoire
donc là on est à fond puis tout va bien
se passer pour que lundi lundi jour de
bouclage on est finie not ready n'est
fini tous nos articles et qu'ils soient
prêts distribués dès le mardi matin
qu'est ce qu'il y aura dans cette
première gazette 50 en 2010 quand on
peut imaginer en une par exemple on a un
appareil tout à l'heure la fusion alors
c'est pas une fusion mais le
rapprochement en tout cas maurepas
coignard en une commune nouvelle pas
vous dévoiler tous les sujets qui sont
traités dedans il y aura pas mal à
découvrir dès mardi mais en effet le
sujet de la fusion maurepas coignières
serait évidemment dedans ça sera pas la
une la une sera sera un autre sujet
alors notre sujet de territoire mais on
trouvera je vous dévoile pas les sujets
mais il y aura évidemment la fusion
coignard maurepas
donc si page complète d'actualité locale
sur des thématiques variées deux pages
de faits divers une page de sport de
comptes rendus de rencontrer d'annonce
d'événements sportifs très bien et une
page complète d'annonce d'événements
culturels
alors la gazette paraît déjà dans nos
tribunes en tout cas une édition un
horrible in une édition qui est dédié à
ce secteur du département il ya combien
de tirage sur le secteur et et combien
de lecteurs avez vous dans leur est
venue alors dans le nord yvelines la
gazette en yvelines couvre la communauté
urbaine grand paris seine et oise
donc c'est toutes les communes qui vont
de mantes-la-jolie rosny-sur-seine jusqu
à conflans sainte honorine poissy ça
fait soixante treize communes pour
quatre cinq mille habitants très bien et
le titre est tiré à 60 mille exemplaires
par semaine
combien de lecteurs là c'est dur a
estimé parce qu'avec un gratuit un taux
de rebond vu que le journal gratuit les
gens se l'approprient pas forcément il a
tendance à vivre que ce soit dans les
transports en commun les gens le
laissent d'autre le récupère c'est dur
estimé moi le seul chiffre que je peux
vraiment vous donner c'est soixante
mille exemplaires distribué toutes les
semaines et sur saint quentin en
yvelines quels sont les objectifs
on part sur des premiers tirages
aux environs de 40 mille exemplaires et
l'objectif à terme c'est cinquante mille
exemplaires avec 230 mille habitants on
estime que ça consiste c'est déjà un
beau chiffre on dire un mot sur le fait
que l'hebdomadaire est gratuit dans un
instant la formule hebdomadaire ça
permet aussi de traiter les sujets avec
un peu plus de recul
ça nous laisse nous plus de temps en
effet sur certains sujets de d'abord de
se renseigner de deux peut-être avoir
plus d'interlocuteur c'est un autre
format qui qui en plus et va en synergie
avec tout ce qui est déjà proposée
actuellement que vous l'avez dit à saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya une richesse de médias locaux
c'est assez forte donc nous le format de
données d'air nous paraît nous paraît
bon pour traiter les différents sujets
qu'on veut aborder la gazette
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça sera un
hebdomadaire gratuit
quel est le modèle économique du coup
comme on arrive à se rémunérer sur sur
ce genre de publication c'est très
simple on fonctionne uniquement avec la
publicité c'est notre seule et unique
source de revenus ou pourquoi on pourra
trouver pardon où pourra-t-on trouver
cette gazette de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors là on est en train de déployer
dans ce qu'on appelle des présentoirs
c'est des petites boîtes comme dans
lequel on peut parler journal les
journaux comme par exemple le comme ça
fait pour le 20 minutes donc dans un
premier temps sera essentiellement à
priori présents dans les gares à
proximité des supermarchés puis à terme
sera vraiment déployer sur toutes les
communes avec plus d'une centaine de
points de distribution
il nous reste un peu moins d'une minute
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter la
pour ses premiers jours la première
publication qui arrive mardi prochain
réussir à boucler le journal lundi ce
sera déjà un très bon début et puis que
mardi bas les lecteurs soient au
rendez-vous et qu'on arrive à avec notre
une des intéressés à tous prendre le
journal est à lire presque dans son
intégralité pourquoi pas merci à damien
à égayer d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous rédacteur en chef de ce nouveau
venu à saint quentin en yvelines la
gazet de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
l'hebdomadaire gratuit apparaîtra pour
la première fois mardi à 17 17 avril
prochain il ya un site internet alors
qui est peut-être pas encore en service
mais qui sera prochainement servir à
terme et il s'affiche d'ailleurs en bas
de l'écran
merci d'avoir été un texto à la
direction un concours à présent des
élèves de seconde du lycée de villa roy
ont pu tester aujourd'hui
mercredi leurs talents d'orateur ils ont
déclamé des poèmes écrits dans le cadre
d'un projet culturel depuis le début de
l'année scolaire
ils ont été épaulés par un poète
rhapsodes aurélie rose était sur place
après plusieurs mois d'écriture et
d'entraînement ces élèves de seconde du
lycée de villa roi partage aujourd'hui
leur création dans le cadre du parcours
d'éducation artistique et culturelle un
projet qui a démarré en septembre
dernier
le but est de partager la poésie celle
qu'on lit celle qu'on apprend et celle
qu'on écrit soi même en étant dans les
traces des poètes qu'on étudie et en
suivant les traces d'un poète bien
vivant impôts est bien vivant qui se
nomme yves godin les élèves ont pu le
rencontrer à plusieurs reprises lors
d'ateliers au début ce n'était pas trop
chaud parce que c'est pas trop mon truc
les poètes tous à l'arrêt comme c'était
yves godard après on a appris à le
connaître et tout et j'ai bien minime et
vous pour les aider à prendre confiance
en tout l'environnement qui était
guettée avec eux que ce soit l'espace
des gens qui nous a permis à chacun moi
y compris de nous libérer de plein de
préjugés et donc d'avoir de l'à-propos
poétique
une approche qui a conquis les jeunes
poètes yvon godin le personnage on a
bien aimé une amie tout à l'aise et j'ai
l'intention nous a plus aidé à être à
l'aise à comment rester nos prêts mais
il nous a beaucoup aidés sur l'écriture
aussi
moi ça m'a plu du coup j'ai pris mon
stylo ma plume et j'ai commencé à
rédiger
je pensais pas que moi je pouvais écrire
quelque chose pour moi c'était réservé
aux grands poètes la trentaine de poèmes
écrits par cette classe de seconde sera
prochainement éditée dans un recueil
intitulé les dormeurs du bal on referme
ce journal sur un rendez vous original
proposé hier à l'ugc skywest une
conférence sur la sorcellerie est là est
animé par la seule sorcière reconnu
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines et en ile
de france un événement dans le cadre du
happy hour business club un club
d'affaires de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
acquis à se réunit tous les mois un
thème de la sorcellerie qui a attiré les
curieux comme vous allez l'entendre au
micro de mie câline d'euros oui ça
existe
après vous n'êtes pas obligé d'y croire
mais oui ça existe c'est ça existe
depuis toujours et d'ailleurs ça a été
même reconnu par toutes les religions
toutes les religions par les admettre
l'existence de la série je vais presque
60 personnes inscrites ce soir ce qui
est déjà pas mal
et voilà donc il ya toujours un côté
curiosité puis la sorcellerie c'est
quand même un thème qui a interpelle
ça peut faire un peu peur ou en tout cas
ça interpelle et pas de sorcellerie mais
de la culture à suivre ce soir dans le
7-8 culture présentée par mélanie poquet
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal merci
de l'avoir suivi une édition à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]